lots of americans are facing a housing
decision and trying to decide whether
they should rent
or buy
is it better to rent or buy in this
environment it seems like people are
stuck between a rock and a hard place
well right now there is a very clear
answer when it comes to which is the
more prudent financial choice you should
rent
i'll explain why
right now is a historically bad time to
buy a home i talked about this back in
april when interest rates first started
rising after years of near record low
rates it's looking like the party may be
over in the mortgage market my
colleagues ben eisemann and nicole
friedman recently found that rents are
increasing around the country but they
aren't rising nearly as fast as the cost
of buying a house well rising mortgage
rates have complicated and already
perplexing housing market for potential
home buyers data from the mortgage
bankers association and the u.s census
bureau show that since the fourth
quarter of 2020 rents have risen by
around 10
mortgage payments have increased by
almost 60 percent
in fact as of the second quarter this
year the median u.s mortgage payment is
almost one and a half times the rate of
median u.s rent that's the highest that
ratio has been since at least 2009. many
economists have long contended that
renting and investing in a stock market
is a better investment than owning a
house and in 2022 that's proving
especially true that's largely because
housing prices have risen so much over
the past two years and this year
mortgage rates have risen along with
them the average monthly mortgage
payment in the u.s jumped by more than
40 percent from the second quarter of
2021 to the second quarter of 2022.
higher home values also mean higher
property taxes so new homeowners are
getting hit with higher costs in three
different ways higher interest rates
higher home prices and higher property
taxes
this is also driving up rents but
landlords are finding that they can only
increase rental prices by so much
the almost 600 monthly difference
between the u.s median rent and median
mortgage payment can be invested along
with what would have been used for a
down payment to create a pretty nice
nest egg home prices are also starting
to come down in many parts of the
country the median sales price for
existing homes fell by ten thousand
dollars in july that's a good thing for
home affordability which is at the
lowest level in decades but ticked up in
july but it also means that home prices
are likely to keep going lower which
could put new home buyers immediately
underwater on their big purchase despite
all of that it's still a very
competitive market the average u.s house
is still receiving multiple offers and
selling less than a month after being
put on the market so bargain-hunting
buyers may find themselves out of luck
even now and don't forget inflation is
still rising at the fastest pace in
nearly 40 years so all those repairs
homeowners have to pay for themselves
will be that much more expensive
owning a house is nice but as the great
bust of rhymes told us in 1997 make sure
you're stacking your ones floss a little
and vest up in a mutual fund
that's all for now see you next time
you